Everybody Hello, hello Hey guys.
Oh my gosh, my throat.
I know me.
Let me get my was that also dad's here, but he's not actually here He's like he's like he's at the sitter now.
He's at the Dog sitter, but he's here, but he's not actually here, but he's here but like not really
Yes, so I put him at the sitter because you know, there's a concert on There's a concert on Saturday guys.
I may or may not only stream Very little tomorrow.
I'm sorry guy.
Okay, depending on how my voice is tomorrow
It's okay guys, I think Marvel Rivals might actually cook dad a war
I think I think I think Marvel Rivals
He's like I'm gonna get that Chinese medication real quick like the we're like for like throat and stuff to me That's so funny that's so fucking funny Okay, I'll be right back guys I'm so sorry I'll be right back
Hey, all right.
I sound a lot better now.
Thank you What am I thinking myself?
We're doing a good job I'd clearly take care of myself.
Um, but hello everybody.
Hello.
Hello guys Oh, I'm gonna turn my humidifier on I'm trying to like do some self-care as I played
Played and stream Rivals
As I played and streamed Marvel Rivals for like 20 22 hours in the span of three days, so Hi Look, I'm a peak human being right there But yes, today's a very special day is a very very special day for those who don't know I got top 500 Marvel Rivals and 800k subscribers Yeah I'm so happy.
I'm so so happy.
Oh my god, I'm Really really happy that You know, we're here.
This journey was long, but we've made it.
I Mean technically it wasn't that long.
It was like not even a year That we made it like we literally sped run a whole tire of youtuber career within less than a year and like in 2025 I'm definitely gonna slow down a little bit just a little bit I'll slow down because I crammed so many things within 24 because I was like,
oh man What if What if like, you know in 205 I won't get the same opportunities again So then I was like, I won't do this.
I wonder that I would do all of this Every single one of these things.
I want to do it and then now now I'm like, okay 25 I should chill a little bit.
I should chill just a little bit There's so many opportunities and stuff but I have booked a lot of Conventions and stuff for 2025.
So it's gonna be Slowing down, but also not really slowing down.
I'm gonna try and slow down.
So we'll see how it goes
Yeah, cuz I don't have visited every every like area yeah, I want to meet as many dragons as possible Oh, yes, and then there's rest of tuber 2025 But I haven't figured out how to like improve on that yet So we'll see how that one goes.
I haven't really thought about the plans for WrestleTuber At the moment but I mean there's still a long way to go I'm gonna make it around the same time as always like around the same month as always so like You can like know exactly when to expect it.
But thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
But yes, today's a very special day There's a very special announcement Today, I can't say what it is yet.
I had a lot of trouble deciding what to do for the announcement because like The announcement itself is at 7 and I was like, what the fuck do I do?
We were like, oh, you know, they would have like karaoke's and like stuff like that for special streams But I'm like, I don't know what to do.
I'm just gonna I Guess I'm just gonna be here.
I Thought it'd be fun to do like some Some like voice requests like cameos and stuff like live cameo You'll be like I want you to do this.
I'll be like, alright, you know I sound a little fucked up at the moment, but I'm gonna rest my throat tomorrow So, um, I'm I'm sorry that basically this entire week has basically been Marvel Rivals Marvel Rivals plus this
I'm so sorry.
This has been it's like apex week.
But now now it's Marvel Rivals week
But at least you saw like my clown arc it was like people were like this is like I found it funny that we basically made a Trilogy of sorts so it was like So we basically had like a trilogy of a journey from like happiness the first movie was happiness with a little despair and then descend and then slowly descending into madness and Then and then and then madness then depression Then my joker arc then full-on fucking hate and then and then we got it And then the raid boss and then we got it No,
thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you Top 100 for 2025 No, no, I just want to end at top 500.
I don't really care.
I won't rank.
I just wanted to be like Top 100.
It's gonna be very difficult, especially when uh The hardest part the hardest thing that i'm most worried about is the fact that um You know like every day people are figuring out new meta and new tech And then we all have to basically learn something new Every day I have to learn Something new every day while playing because they're coming up with new strategies because nothing is established yet Nothing is fully established in the grand scheme of things So I'm like so like that's the most difficult part because it's obviously it's gonna get harder It's gonna get a lot harder the more the more days pass.
So I think um Um, so I think like That's it's gonna be very difficult.
So like top ending top 500.
I think it's possible But I think it's definitely possible especially if I like keep playing Almost every like I don't have to play every day because I won't be able to play in the next three days Which sucks because you know, everybody's climbing in the next three days every day because I have to play catch up I might play a little bit more off stream today Um after i'm done with my work just so I don't have to play do too much catch up I want to make sure that like,
you know, I don't have to do too much catch up when it comes to the lobbies and um And like um, and then like I don't have to worry about grinding like a hell a lot Um after three days has passed because I feel like I feel like Just like overwatch 2 when overwatch 2 first came out top 500 was literally grandmaster 1 Which was like the highest rank you could possibly get and then um And then I feel like in marvel rivals I feel like there is gonna be like,
you know, I feel like uh They're gonna have it's gonna be like There's not it's gonna be like the toppest ranks of marvel rivals like grandmaster, what was the grand it wasn't grandmaster It was like the next one.
I don't remember.
I don't remember the tier above grandmaster but I don't even know when the season ends too.
That's the biggest worry I have I don't know what the season the lat the when it's ending.
So If it's really long we're fucked Ha ha ha
We're so fucked if it's a very long season So, oh, is it the end of december Oh, it's 20 more days.
Okay, that's doable.
That's actually really doable I'll just not have anything to do after the call.
I'll just play after the concert Um people like rest don't play.
Well playing marvel rivals is my rest not gonna lie Because like I really enjoy the game.
I actually like i'm so addicted to marvel rivals It makes it reminds me of when I first started playing overwatch um, and how fucking Addicted I was where I would spend.
Um Um 12 plus hours playing every day because I just I love the game so much and that's how I feel right now Because everybody's actually trying to Because they're not depressed yet
They're They're not depressed yet And like pessimistic about life and about the game.
Everyone's hopeful and happy And like willing to work together So they're not depressed yet So like things are looking bright and shiny and then later on the honeymoon phase is gonna It's gonna come in and then things are gonna get worse.
So like i'm enjoying The honeymoon phase right now of all the players that are in my lobby because everyone's happy at the moment in the higher elo I feel like I feel like the top 500 players.
Everyone's very happy right now So so i'm enjoying that before it's gone.
Um Oh, yeah, um momo.
Thank you.
This is akasupa.
Thank you Uh, congrats on 800k doki I know that this is like pennies to you, but know that you have lots of latino dragoons out there Or is this what see a million maybe someday the world tour will come to your home.
Thank you for the akasupa Thank you.
Thank you.
Oh my gosh.
Hello latino latino dragoons.
Hello.
Hello Honestly, any type of support means so much because I invest a lot of it back into my own channel back into you guys So thank you so much.
I really appreciate it because I know that's a lot for your own currency So I really appreciate that for the support.
Um, speaking of like, um speaking of like, um Latinos, I love latinos Um, um, my management team is actually trying to look into like conventions in south america Um and like other places that we haven't gone to yet So let's hope that next year we can get something um Next year in 2025.
I hope we do.
I'd love to see some of my uh, Latino dragoons down there too.
Um, so it'll be pretty cool if we can honestly, I don't know how it'll work because I feel like especially like you know I feel like it might be a little difficult just because you know, um, I don't know vtubers are popular in south america So or like just for for like english-speaking vtubers too in general So like I hope that I hope I hope they I hope we can get something Um,
it's mostly about like them requesting me because we get a lot of convention requests and we mostly I mostly say yes To a majority of them because it's like, you know, it gives me an opportunity to speak to you guys and everything.
Um, so um But this is the first time we actually are requesting to like trying to see if we can get a convention um in South america by us like approaching some so it will if you guys really want me to see me in south america Encourage your conventions to like email me and then like we can like negotiate something with them,
too So yeah, I love meaning I don't like a lot of vtubers too.
Don't really um, it's really difficult difficult for indie vtubers, too Um to like do like conventions and stuff like that because like, you know, a lot of conventions tend to just look at like a corporate side Um, because it's easier to gather people on the corporate side.
Um, but like, um i'm trying my best to like Uh, so like it's like it's like I feel really fortunate that a lot of conventions approach me Especially those that are like not just centric to vtubers ask me to come to you know Come to meet some of my fans there too.
So I really appreciate that and um, And it it's you know, obviously I don't want to take things for granted and stuff So I always try my best to do as many as I can Because you know, it's a great opportunity to see some of you guys Down there to see all the support and you guys can make some new friends with other dragons and everything too And then like,
you know buy some doki merch too there and support like local artists, um at your convention that draw me um And so it's like it's always like really cool to uh, um It's always really cool to be able to do that and have the opportunity because I know a lot of indies Don't really have that opportunity.
So i'm trying to I don't want to take it for granted or anything So, um, that's why I always try to do as much as I can and I think it also helps me a lot as well, it's like a Um, it's like, you know, it's a give and take too So like, um i'm putting myself out there for people who might not know who I am and they see this giant screen of an anime girl and Be like,
who the fuck is that girl?
And I was like, that's me.
I'm doki.
That's me.
That's me Um, but yeah, um gambit thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you latinos rise up Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you Um cosmic dawn.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you rise up mi gente Thank you for the super chat.
Oh my gosh I think it's also my lemon tea, too.
Um, well, it's the hong kong style I'm drinking dongling cha right now.
I think that's like closing my throat more.
I think if I have warm water I wouldn't sound as raspy, but i'm drinking like dongling cha right now Um also like oh my gosh, my cantonese has degraded so much because I haven't spoken cantonese in a long ass time so like Hahaha Because I live alone now,
so I haven't really spoken cantonese at all so like i'm like, uh Oh cold drinks are bad.
Oh Oh, okay.
Give me a sec.
I'm gonna get warm water.
I'm gonna Baby, i'm sorry.
I love cold drinks.
Okay.
Give me a sec.
I'm gonna get warm water.
Give me a sec All
right All right.
I'm kettling right now.
I didn't realize cold drink.
I forgot cold drinks are Are not as are like not good for your throat.
That's my bad.
I didn't realize that i'm alone.
I'm a little stupid.
Um Loli, thank you.
Let's super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you Uh, congrats on 800k Proud to have you as my oshi through thick and thin all these years Last year at state at a state vod playing while sitting in a power outage midwinter.
Thanks for keeping spirits up then Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you I really appreciate it guys.
Wow There's so many 800,000 of you guys are subscribed.
Okay.
I don't know how to i'm gonna say again though I am very i'm so confused how the fuck I got like 2.5k people subscribing me in the last two days because of marvel rivals I
I don't know how that happened.
I was like that was a lot Within just two days.
That's a lot Because like I I wasn't doing anything special or anything.
I was just I was just playing marvel rivals.
So So like I was I guess it's also because like there's not a lot of like Vtubers right now that's grinding marvel rivals and higher elo and like Um, they want to learn how to play the support or something or I don't know.
They just want to watch me suffer They just want to watch me suffer So so I was like thank you for subscribing if you came from my marvel rivals stuff, I really appreciate it Thank you so much.
Um Laffy thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm happy.
I get to watch you this year It's been very fun and I hope to for many more years to come happy 800k and hopefully 1 million Try going next year.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Me too.
I hope I get a million next year That's michael.
Also speaking of 800k Celebration stream.
I'll be having that in 2025 in january because I was planning something for it.
But like, um Um, I didn't expect it to get it this month Because like originally I had a plan for uh december Um, like as like christmas ish, but then I was like I have something else.
I want to release on christmas So I decided to push that one Later just because I was like, oh, I want to release something else instead.
So I was like i won't release that I'll do the celebration in january instead because like I want to release the Thing I have on christmas everything i'm working other thing I was working on on christmas instead and have Um the celebration in january just because like there's a lot of stuff going on behind the scenes.
So i'm like More pause thinking about 10 get the chips thinking.
Thank you Uh pal tonight thinking about the super chat thinking.
Thank you Uh, i'm driving over six hours on saturday to see the concert.
It'll be worth it.
I hope you guys enjoy it I hope you guys enjoy it I'm, i'm so nervous because I know i'm not a singer and I was like i'm really nervous because mint sounds amazing And then there's me I tried my best Mint mint sounds amazing mint.
Oh my god mint was like such a Such a good singer and i'm like, oh my god, i'm trying my best And then there's me because like when we were rehearsing when we're rehearsing and I was listening to her sing I was like Oh my god How do I compare?
How do I compare to her?
And then like when she was practicing her dances and singing when we were together Two weeks ago or three weeks ago.
I was like, how do I compare?
What do I do?
So just remember She is the more experienced one And i'm just jokey I'm, just ken I'm the ken to the barbie basically i'm like the assessor
I'm the plus one at the concert
Also like she actually picked real songs and then
Okay Okay my set list My set list is very special because like I was like I didn't I I sort of did not pick real songs.
I That you'll hear at a concert.
I So and then they're like no follow i'm gonna I can't be well Don't worry.
Someone will record it and then you'll know why I said that the oh no and i'll no I also upload One of the songs upload one of the songs Because I know what i'm uploading because we're uploading two songs a solo and a solo and a duet on each of our channels,
um And uh doobie's gonna upload, uh the her the the doobie's gonna upload, uh uh stuff too so like We're all uploading stuff.
So yeah So you guys won't miss out So you guys won't miss out anything So yeah, uh, so don't worry i'm gonna get i'm gonna be uploading i'm gonna be uploading like The the really fucked up song that I picked
Um, um, but yeah, yeah, i'm pretty sure the other girls can upload stuff too they want um Um, but I am I'm, very i'm very excited.
What do you mean fucked up?
Well, you'll see you'll hear You'll find out on saturday, even if you can't be there You'll find out on saturday because i'll be uploading one of them.
You'll my setlist.
Yes mint did not approve my set list she like um She was very disappointed in some of the songs I picked so
Oh shit, okay.
Okay.
We got three minutes left.
I'm gonna go get my hot water before before like this thing starts.
Give me a sec
All right, i'm back Sorry, I keep going in and out.
I had a lot of work to do Um after the stream I was just catching up on all the work that I procrastinated on because I was too busy playing marvel rivals Um, i'm so sorry data war fans That you guys got cooked yet again Um You got you guys got cucked yet again Shut up we still went You still judged me you judged me Oh my god anyway,
okay, so Oh two more minutes two more minutes Guys thank you.
Thank you.
Thank you No, they won't they'll cheer me on I want to hear it.
They'll cheer me on They'll be like I can't believe she did that.
Wow She's so brave She's so fucking brave
You guys will love it.
Yeah
You're just jealous you're just jealous I thought outside of the box I was thinking outside of the box.
I was giving a unique Experience those who have like been to like vtuber concerts would never experience something as As unique as what I bring to the table
Um Let's see koala.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you Will any of the merch from the concert be sold online also congrats on 800k.
Thank you super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you Yes, they will also your favorite super chat, thank you so much Yes, they will be so do not worry.
We have some merch that will be sold online After the concert so, uh, don't have to worry for those who might want to Uh get the merch some of the merch will be sold online after the concert Um, even you can't attend it.
Oh my god.
Okay.
All right special announcement But A special announcement
Calling all units there's been a break-in a suspect is a doki bird She's wearing her iconic thief outfit.
But be advised her pose is changeable with swappable arms and articulated legs She's accompanied by her accomplices a crow mean croaky and a little dragoon she holds in her hand Be aware her true form is a tomato.
So be on the lookout Suspect may be found standing on the special nendoroid base with her signature on it Ah, she got away again Catch me yeah dragons
Oh wait, but you already announced this doki, why did you show this again because You can order it right now Yeah
Yes, I have the link right here, let me grab the link actually let me grab the link because it's up right now on the website Is it working?
Okay.
Oh shit.
Okay um Sorry, there's a lot of people on there's a lot of people on it right now The site is down Oh my god Okay, sorry There's a queue now Did you guys crashed it Like okay, it's working.
All right, it's out now Free nendoroid is out now.
You can pre-order it Holy shit, I can't believe you guys you guys already crashed the website.
That's like crazy So if you order it from the website, um, you can get two special exclusive bonuses, uh, the the printed badge Um badge button and also an actual unique base.
Um A unique base That with my signature on it Um, but yeah, i'm really excited.
Um, thank you guys so much for the support.
This was basically announcement Uh Yeah, we we accidentally sort of um ddos the site whoops that is My bad, they were like, oh, yeah, let me let us know what time What time you're gonna be in doing the announcement and I was like, oh i'll just announce that exactly Exactly 7 p.m.
Um, because that's when it's gonna go live.
So they're like, all right Yeah, we'll make sure we're gonna make sure we have it out on time and everything.
But oh my god Now you can see all the different expressions the different expressions uh poses um hands and everything Uh, no, there's no code.
It's just you click on that link and um, and also, uh, like I said, um the more People who buy oh, yeah, and the hat is removable by the way You can the hat is removable.
So like I said the more people who buy an android the higher chance um the higher the chance that um, we can have a second android, um of my current of my current, uh skin suit also since you know, you know, since it's a very special occasion, um, let me uh,
let me disappear for a second because You know, it's a very special occasion.
I didn't want to I had to you know decide Exactly like Oh, should I put on my old skin suit or not?
because I but then you guys would know exactly what the announcement is if I put it on because you'll be like why the Fuck is she?
Why the fuck does she have it on?
So I had to like, you know, I have to be like, oh I can't let you guys know exactly what i'm thinking of Thinking about oh my gosh.
Okay.
Give me a sec I need a Sorry, i'm gonna ruin your immersion a little bit
Sorry, all right, here we go.
All right Since you know, this is a very special occasion.
I figured you know, I should put on my old skin suit to Um to announce, you know the special nendoroid I should put on my retro suit.
Um, but yeah, i'm so happy that It's finally here um I honestly I never ever thought I would ever get an android of myself Not even like in the before times.
I actually thought I would get an android.
So the fact that You know Especially because it's really rare for indies to have this opportunity like you can you can count your on one hand I think it's one hand one, two, three, four or five one or two hands one to two hands Because I might be missing so because I know there's like,
you know There's also indies from like not just like english indies But like I know there's some indies in jp or like in asia that also got nendoroids too but I think like in general it's very um rare to see an indie vtuber um Get an android so I want to say thank you guys so much uh for the support and For allowing me to be able to you know Get something that I never expect to ever have to own Or half of me,
so it really means a lot guys, and I hope you guys Enjoyed the nendoroid whenever I don't even remember when it's coming out out officially Uh quarterly, okay time of shipment Uh, oh, okay time of shipment is quarterly 1 2026.
So yeah, I really do.
Oh, it's like, you know a christmas present for you guys It's next year's christmas present.
Um, oh my god.
They have avatar ang Sorry, I'm not I didn't know they made the oh my god.
Wait, what do you have an avatar?
And then okay, it's been a while since I collected nendoroids.
Oh my god.
I did not know that I'm looking at Recommended i'm looking at recommended right now
Um um But um, yeah, thank you guys so much Uh, sorry, I got distracted because I was like, whoa the avatar has nendoroids now
Um I think it was more so production too so because they I didn't know how many they have to make how many they have to make and then uh, And then they'll like they'll ship out the amount and stuff because I know pre-order dates It's usually around that long if it just came out like,
uh, have you ever ordered nendoroids before?
from like really the release statement to like when Um when it starts shipping them Um, they usually take around that long because they got it's like production time, especially nendoroids I know because I know because I used to chase after Nendoroid releases for in asia.
Your nendoroid will release on august 2025 Guys okay.
Here's the plan.
Um You buy one for in asia and then you buy one in na and then you race to see You know you get you get the display one from na You order one from na for the display and then you order this the first one in the one you want now From asia and then like so you can use it now.
Okay.
That's such a terrible wording Why did I say that?
Um, so you can have it sooner, but it's not the display one.
It's not the display
And then and then you'll have two or maybe three or make your own collect make an army of croquis and tomatoes
Isn't that fun Isn't that Is that fun a collection of croquis and tomatoes this tiny little fucking croquis over there
Your own little croquis army, yeah I was so happy that they were able to make croquis and the tomato because they're like What kind of accessories do you want?
And I was like I want I I honestly I I didn't expect them to be Because like, you know, you're so limited With I thought i'd be more limited with what I can have Because like there's some nendoroids where there's like nothing, you know I I didn't realize I was so free to have so many things because I know like,
you know some nendoroids You just have like, you know One or two like hand pieces And then like expressions and then that's it But then I got to even have like because when I was like, I have croquis and tomato and they're like Yeah, of course you can and I was so surprised because like I thought they would sacrifice like hand pieces for it But then I also have like the hard hands hand piece too for my nendoroid So I was like,
I was really happy about that, too.
So You know, there's a lot of variety and also like, you know the dragoon as well So i'm glad that my I know like these accessories are not universal type deal As in like you can't have it you can't like, you know use it for other nendoroids I guess because like what contest that doesn't make sense in any context,
you know, so It doesn't it doesn't it doesn't make much sense, you know my accessories and stuff like that Um, but like but that's why it's unique because it works for me Because because it's it's like a doki bird Um, it's like a doki bird nendoroid It won't come out till 2026.
Well, if you buy if you're if you live in asia, it comes out in august
Yeah I think it's also shipment because they have to ship it to the states And then then in the states that they ship it to you guys So like because they have to order it from the to the states, but you live in asia It comes back it comes from japan, obviously.
So, um So it's quicker because of that because it's easier it like the shipment is Easier too.
So like, um, if you're in asia and you got a friend in the states If you have if you have a friend in the states, you know help help a dragoon out
How long is the pre-order window that's a very good question let me check Oh, yeah The canada post strike is really bad right now as in like what do you mean by really bad?
um we they said that It doesn't look like it's gonna end anytime soon.
So And then they suspended the u.s.
The u.s.
Post office suspended sending things to us Because they're like what the the state the american post office is like what the fuck is going on And they're like we have so much backlog to canada, but we can't do anything about it So now they suspended all services From to canadians and also like what's it called?
Perlotaur the one for that amazon uses this is they also suspended services to us Because they're like bro.
We don't know what to do with you guys We don't we don't know what to do if you We don't know what to do with you guys.
I'm like, that's fair
Oh, it's up until thank you guys you guys are so much more professional than me.
I really
I'm You guys are homies guys help with them help remember to help but don't keep bird now Pre-orders last until february Uh february what I don't remember what the date was Help a homie out I don't even know wait.
Is that true?
I don't even know if that was true.
You just made up a date Okay nendoroid pre-order All right, february 5th, okay nice yeah, that's how long the pre-order is All right, i'm excited i'm so excited though, um, I cannot wait I I honestly I think the one thing i'm most excited about are people making like,
uh Taking pictures of it and everything.
I'm really excited about that seeing people like pose them and uh, Taking like nice pictures or making like videos of it and everything So that's what i'm looking forward to you have to stop motion stuff, too Oh my god, I used to like I used to um, I used to be on my figure collection um And I was like crazy obsessed over like Over that website because I used to be a hardcore collector.
I was a hardcore hardcore collector Of figures and everything and then I would look like I would love looking at like the top trending pictures And stuff like photos people took of their figures and everything And um, it honestly was like, oh my gosh,
i'm gonna be that's gonna be me Oh my god.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna have a i'm gonna have a my figure collections uh Category.
That's so crazy.
That's actually so crazy You know, you know what?
My dream was like I always been like, oh man My my my biggest now.
I just need a funko pop to complete the trifecta Right now i'm i'm gonna wait until the funko pop drama dies down I'm gonna put that dream on hold now because yeah Due to recent events that dream is now on hold
Due to recent events Wait, what happened?
Well, they like they they like shut down itch.io because like um Via like an ai bot shut down itch.io because it basically Shuts down ips of like things that are like, you know harms the trademark Um, but because it's an ai Um, it just automatic did that and it was and then so So that's what happened.
And then um, obviously itch.io was like the fuck and it's back now itch.io is back It took 24 hours And then the thing is because he's the owner you can say what the fuck he wants So then apparently funko pop called his mom And then his mom was like what the fuck?
Why did they call?
Me and then the owner of the site posted it on twitter about it.
So yeah, it's not a lot Yeah, they called him out publicly.
So like because you know, they're not governed by anything, you know, they're just like They're just like I could do whatever the fuck I want.
What are they gonna do?
I own my own website They like they like they like ran to tell his mom yeah, I Honestly, I thought that too I was like, what is he like 10?
Like why did you snitch on like?
He's an adult Why did you fucking why did you call his mom?
They ran and tell his fucking mom i'm gonna tell on you yeah, i'm gonna tell your fucking mom um And then mom was like I received a phone call from a lawyer talking about how you publicly called them out like call me back Gerald call me back gerald f uh gatsby You better call me back right this instance
I should show a little bit harder here.
Okay, give me a sec.
Nendoroid out now.
They work so fast though.
Working with Nendoroid was actually, was actually like really great experience because they work incredibly fast.
I was very surprised with how, how fast they worked in general.
Because like, which makes sense because you know when an anime gets like super fucking popular and then they instantly have, they like instantly have something for it.
So like, it like, which makes sense because they're like, you know, they gotta like catch on the hype before it's too late and everything.
So they're so, they're stiff, they're like so like, they were, they did this so fast, like I was not expecting everything to go so fast.
Okay, I need like, let's see.
I want like a bigger, let's see, I'll turn down, boop.
And so I can do Nendoroid out now.
Whoa!
Okay, and then I want big, a better font.
There we go.
Yeah, Nendoroid out now.
No, that's not shilled enough.
Okay, there we go.
Cuz now you'll have to see it.
My, my text is up here.
My eyes are up here.
That's right, my eyes are right here.
You can't skip this ad.
What, you judging my fucking eyes?
I was born with text eyes.
Are you a fucking hater?
Anyway guys, so yeah.
Wait, we have a better idea.
Wait a minute, wait a minute.
Oh no, that's way too much.
Okay, no, I have a better idea.
Okay, give me a sec.
I gotta, I gotta be able to shill this properly.
Okay, what do I use?
Aero black, right?
Alright, give me a sec, guys.
Guys, I am like a businesswoman.
I'm a ruthless businesswoman.
That's fucking right.
Okay, I need to, like, make sure I can make this properly.
I, witness, don't say that.
Witness protection ad.
Okay, where is it?
Nendoroid out now.
Okay, and then make sure this is white text.
And then, and then, what does it look like?
Okay, like that.
And it was, and I used Aero black, right?
Okay, Aero bold.
Where's bold?
Okay, there we go.
Does it look like this?
Yeah, it does.
Alright, this is perfect.
This is exactly what I needed.
Alright, my ad is almost complete.
Guys, if you guys want to purchase ad space, let me know.
If anyone wants to purchase ad space, just let me know.
I'll put it on my body.
Alright, let's see.
Where did I put it?
Oh, it's right here.
Alright, okay, give me a second.
I'm going to disappear for a sec, guys.
Just look at the text.
Okay, just make sure you see the text properly.
I'm going to do something.
I'm going to be a good, a good worker.
I don't need this anymore.
Okay, there we go.
My eyes are up here.
My eyes are... That's right.
Where are you looking at, huh?
That's looking right.
Where the fuck are you looking at?
That's right.
Did you pre-order your Nendoroid yet?
Because it's out now.
Don't think you don't see it.
Like, I don't know how much obvious I can make it for you that it's out now.
I can't read.
That's right.
That's right, you get it right now if you click on the link.
Oh wait, no, you can still see those eyes in me.
There we go.
That's much better.
Now, now it's my actual eyes.
Alright, yeah, so anyway, if you click on the...
Okay, let me... Wait, actually, let me... It's a little bit too big.
There we go, now it's perfect.
So yeah, if you click on the link on the description, you can... Wait, oh my god, where is it?
Alright, if you click on the link on the description, you'll be able to get to the website and then pre-order it.
Like I said, there's like bonus items for it.
So, you know, pretty exciting.
The Doki billboard is real.
That's right, who wants to buy some ad space on the Doki billboard?
Who wants to buy ad space right now?
I think it was Super Chat, not so deadpool.
Thank you, thank you.
You know, like I did like voice requests and live cameos and we've done none of that.
What?
Okay, we're not hot tub streamers, guys.
And also for $10?
Do you know how much it costs to buy a billboard at the New York... The New... Was it the New York Times Square?
Do you guys know how much that is?
You think... You think an ad space for that much is $10?
I am practically the New York Times Square right now.
Like if you look out on the street and you see 2,000 people at the New York Times Square, like that's me.
I don't know how much it is either, but like I know it's not fucking $10.
Okay, how about $11 then, Doki?
Oh my god, I... You know what?
No, I'm even better than the New York Times Square.
I'm the fucking sphere in Las Vegas right now because I can interact with you guys.
I'm almost 3D on Saturday.
Um, various...
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Would you do it for a scooby snack?
Would you do it for a rink roink?
What about a rink roink?
Oh my god, wait, was it $50,000?
Oh my god, what am I at?
$90.
Thank you for the magenta soup, Various.
Thank you, thank you.
Um, I really appreciate it.
Oh my god, John, the only one that's here for the actual streaming part.
Uh, John, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Uh, I have a simple voice request.
I love you, dragons.
There.
You guys deserve that because without your support, I wouldn't be able to, you know, get my nendoroid because, you know, they see how passionate you guys are and how... how much love you give me that, like, I was given an opportunity to get a nendoroid.
Oh my god, this is so dumb.
Look, I'm... I'm looking at myself right now.
Um, and... and this is...
I'm not a person anymore.
I'm just... I am the New York Times Square.
Um, Mr. Sam, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
That's going up.
Will you do it for $200?
Okay, what was it?
All right, that buys you, like, five minutes on the Doki Times Square.
Um, I am...
I'll give you five minutes on the Doki Times Square.
Okay, you're lucky that, um, that... and that's me being generous right now.
I'm... I'm being generous for you guys.
All right, give me a sec, export.
Bro, I'm creating a new meta.
Someone's gonna steal this idea and then, like, use it.
Or maybe it's already been used.
I feel like a lot of things have already been done for, um, in the vtubing sphere.
So maybe somebody's already done that for, like, a subathon or some shit or a donathon.
I'll never... for those who are wondering, I'll never do a donathon or a subathon because I personally have enough support from you guys.
Um, overall that...
I don't have to do something like that, which I really appreciate.
I'm very fortunate.
I'm really fortunate to be in the place where I personally don't have to do a subathon slash donathon because your support is more than enough, um, that, uh, that I'm able to not have to do... do any of them.
And honestly, like, they can, like, fuck you up, fuck your body up a lot and your voice because, like, um, you know, I don't have, like, you know, like, they're... they're, like, a long-term commitment and, um, and, like, because, you know, you always have to be,
like, you have to stream every day without a break basically.
And some people do, like, uncapped subathons and, like, uncapped subathons and, like, donathons and stuff like that.
So, like, I'm very fortunate to be in a place where I don't have to do that.
And it's because of you guys' support and everything that I'm able to, like, you know, just stream when I want to stream.
And I do still stream a lot because I always love streaming and everything.
Um, so, that's why, like, uh, I personally will never do it just because, like, I don't see a reason to on my end to do it just because, like I said, like, um, I can find a lot of things with your current support at the moment, uh, right now.
I don't know if next year it'll change.
So, but for now, for now, I'm okay.
For now, for now, I'm okay at the moment.
Um, and, like, I know, like, for some, like, like, um, but yeah, I'm just, I'm just happy to, I'm just happy to be able to, to be able to, you know, stream for you guys, um, without having to, like, uh, you know, I, I'm, I don't want to fuck up my body even more,
basically, because I already fucked up my voice a little bit.
I, and I'm not aiming for any record or anything.
So, like, in terms of, you know, because I know, like, you know, our mouse has done a lot of subathons, um, but she also does it for charity, too, and, um, which is very upstanding for her, and also, like, uh, for, like, the record and everything.
But I didn't hear, I'm not here to break any records here.
I'm just here to be me, Dohebird, um, and I, honestly, I don't think I could ever, I could barely do a 24-hour stream.
I don't think I could ever do a 24-hour stream.
Oh, did Keso win, win, win the gamer of, what is it, gamer of the year?
Honestly, good for him.
He, I think he's one of the rare streamers that's, like, um, that's actually, like, super unproblematic.
You know?
A con, a content creator.
I know you want, oh, yeah, he won gamer of the year for this stream.
He's, like, um, because I watched a bit of Keso, um, and I don't really watch Keso Keso, but I've seen clips of him.
Because, like, he started out being, like, the guy you watch to make fun of.
But then, it's crazy, because, like, in the beginning of the year, in the beginning of the year, uh, he's, he was, like, just a guy you sort of hate watched, hate watched, or, like, make fun of, because people were always making fun of him.
And then he, like, turned that around.
Like, he actually, like, turned that around, and now he has, like, an actual community and fan base that, like, really likes him.
And, like, he's actually pretty funny.
Like, he's a pretty funny guy.
Um, so good for him.
Be able to turn that around in a year, too.
Um, and he seems very unproblematic, because, like, uh, I don't know.
He seems very unproblematic guy.
Um, he also does, he's also, like, in his own, in his own bubble a lot, too.
Um, he seems pretty chill.
Yeah, I don't really watch him.
I've seen his clips.
I watched one of his streams, because he was playing.
I think he was the one that popularized Dressed to Impress.
Right?
Was it?
Yeah, yeah, he was the one that fucking popularized Dressed to Impress.
Also, like, shout out to Korra, though.
It's, you know, um, huge honor to be, like, um, nominated, too, because, you know, it's, it's such a big thing.
Um, but I also think, because, like, the ga- uh, the Game Awards is very, like, NA-focused.
So, like, it's a lot harder, because people who don't know what VTube, because, like, VTubing is still a niche in NA, but, like, every normie knows who Keso is, so.
So, I feel like it's, it's, like, it, it was, it's definitely, like, a uphill battle for, like, VTubers for that.
Um, because, like, uh, especially if it's not, like, not English-speaking VTubers, because, like, the the people, the normies would be, like, obviously, they'll be, like, I know who Keso is, you know, and they'll just vote for him.
I mean, I know, I know who he is, too.
Yeah, but you're, you only know Pokor- yeah, but you're not a normie.
You're here.
I think I, I must have, like, 10% of, 10%.
The moment, the moment you watch, you might be, like, but, Doki, no.
I'm a normie, too.
No, the moment you start watching my stream, you're no longer a normie.
You're no longer, you're, you're no longer a normie.
The moment you're here, because, first off, why are you on YouTube?
Because normies are all hanging out on Twitch.
There's also that.
There's also that, too.
Like, all the normies are on Twitch.
Why are you on YouTube?
You already revoked your normie card.
You're fucking here.
I hate Twitch.
That's right.
You're not a normie.
You're not a fucking normie if you hate Twitch.
Bro, what's his name?
That, oh my god.
Okay, so, like, I was doing the, the streamer awards, the streamer awards with, with Gumi.
Um, I was like, we were, because, like, she called me from the streamer awards, and then, uh, um, and then, um, I wanted to do an interview thing, the red carpet thing, but we got to the, the beat, the beast role of the red carpet interviews.
And I felt so, I felt so embarrassed, because I never even shout out my name.
They were like, what are you nominated for?
I was like, what do you think I'm nominated for?
Because I'm literally virtual.
I don't even remember who the fuck the interviewer was.
I know he's, like, an IRL streamer, but, like, I don't remember his name, because I don't watch IRL streamers.
Um, because, like I said, I'm not a fucking normie anymore.
I, I'm the most normie, non-normie.
I would say I'm the most normie, non-normie, because, like, um, I watch a lot of normie stuff, like, big, not Big Bang Theory.
Sorry.
I, I fucking hate Big Bang Theory.
Um, what is it called?
Uh, the, the Sheldon one.
Um, god, I already forgot.
Young Sheldon.
I watch Young Sheldon.
I love Young Sheldon.
It's such a good show.
Um, but I watch more.
I don't watch a lot of anime.
I rarely watch anime and stuff like that.
I love Young Sheldon.
Bazonga.
Wait, what?
Wait, fuck.
What was I talking about?
Sorry, I got too conf- I got too, too, like, absorbed into, like, uh, Young Sheldon.
Uh, I already forgot where this topic was going.
I, I also watch, watch the Boss Baby TV show, too.
Um, oh, yeah, the interview.
And then, I was too goomy, because I could see, like, because I was looking at the stream as well.
I was like, how the fuck did the, the NPC Miles Morales get a main interview stage, and I- He's not even a nominee!
I was just like, they gave, like, Miles Morales NPC a main A-stream interview, and he's not even nominated?
Bro, he has to be a plus one!
I was just like, I was like, I was like, I'm nominated!
I'm nominated!
But, like, he's a nominee.
I'm gonna go outside and step on another spider.
Fucking Spider-Man, they're all a problem.
Not just Peter- Not just Peter Parker, they're all a fucking problem.
No, but the NPC Miles Morales became a Twitch streamer, and he was like, I just started, like, a couple of months ago.
I only knew I just found out about Twitch.
Yeah, you didn't, yeah, so like, yeah, so if you're, if you watch on Twitch, you're, you're sort of, like, within the normie sphere and everything.
Um, okay, so yeah, that's, that's, that's my rant of the day.
That's like- They're all a menace to society.
Somebody stop them.
Uh- Oh, yeah, sorry, I was supposed to make an ad, a five-minute ad space.
Oh my, you have, you would have lost your five-minute ad space by now, but you're so lucky.
Okay, let me, let me quickly export this real fast.
All right, here we go.
Okay, let me, um- Oop.
Let me disappear real quick, because we're getting ad space.
We're just putting new ad space on here.
I'll just put it on.
Whoops.
Oh, no, no, no, whoops.
Oh, no, that's not what I wanted.
Okay, we're gonna lock the movement, because I fucked up.
I'll put it right here.
There you go.
There's your, we're gonna give you, like, uh, we're gonna give you, like, five minutes of ad space here.
Remember, I'm the jokey Times Square.
I'm the- That small?
Wow!
That, that, yeah, that's right.
Oh, you, oh, don't, don't, don't, yeah, don't make me- I like how, like, this person who didn't even pay for it is making me angry, so I'm punishing everybody.
Don't make me punish everyone.
All right, five minutes starting now.
44, 142, 43, 44, okay, 44.
All right, we're taking it off at, at 44.
Um, getting never- best, you guys, you get what you paid for.
You get exactly what you paid for, guys.
Guys, I can't believe someone was like, that's- Don't fucking test me right now.
I own this.
I own this billboard.
I own this skill, skin suit.
Don't fucking test me right now.
Don't-
All right, um...
Johnny, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Johnny Lacone.
Uh, Game Dive team rep here.
Our audio maestro, Masha, said they would like some pain grunt noises.
Like, you're getting shot up like Doomguy.
Would that be all right with you?
Okay, that's a private thing.
Um...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You'll get the private files for that.
That's not a lie.
I have BGM.
You just do that?
Oh my god.
I have a BGM music playing right now.
Um, Alan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, in the name of the moon, I'll punish you.
All right, that's your- your custom voice pack while I have this on.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You know, that's a steal.
That's actually a steal, you know.
I like how, like, I'm like, here's some custom voice lines.
Also, I have BGM playing in the background, but- Good luck with that.
Good luck with separating the audio files for that.
I mean, I could have turned the BGM off, but, like, but this is, like, budget voice packs, so, like, you get what you get, so...
I'm planning on releasing, because, like, I know, like, it's been done before, a long time ago, but I'd love to do, like, actual custom voice packs again in the future for, like, merch and stuff that comes with, like, a signed wallpaper and stuff like that.
So I'm definitely thinking about that in the future because I got the wallpaper and stuff done.
I just don't have the time to actually do it yet.
So, maybe in 2025.
Maybe in 2025.
Marianne, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Can I, uh, voice request?
All right.
Oh, and I'm excited for Saturday.
Me too!
I'm so excited!
Oh my gosh.
Burrito, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
I just need you guys to know when, um, when I had those custom voice packs out- by the way, that was the price of what it was.
Um, a hundred dollars.
I think I said that, like, three times to people.
Like, I had three people separately requested that and I'm, like, sick.
That's basically, like, I basically scammed two of them.
No, I'm joking.
I'm joking.
They were- I recorded unique ones for each of them, but I'm joking.
I- I didn't, like, just send them, like, the same file three times, but I've re- I've, you know, of course, I've made new recordings, but I just thought it was so funny.
I thought I thought it was so funny that three people, um, three separate people asked for it, for the limited edition, like, uh, voice packs.
Uh...
Guys, I'm bad, but not that bad.
Like, I would burn trees, but I would not burn trees.
I would not- I would- in my mind, I'd see myself burning trees to feel better because I fucking hate Groot.
Like, I- I can't.
I'm, like, it's been, like, five days of Marble Rivals and I swear if I- oh my god.
It's just- especially when you have two Groot players and all they do is, like, I am Groot.
Groot.
I am Groot.
And you just hear that non-stop for, like, with two Groot players, too.
Two fucking separate Groot players just shouting that all day long.
And I'm- I just- I can't.
I hate that Groot is meta.
I need somebody to bur- to fucking burn his legs.
I- Um,
anyway, um, Marion, um, Meti, I'm gonna beat you with a rock.
There you go.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Um, let's see.
Papa Smurf, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Can we get some motivation to go to the gym?
Oh shit.
Okay, usually I need time to think about that.
I think it was super chat.
Thank you.
So I'm gonna give you, like, something really quick.
Yeah, you go lift those things.
You can do it.
Woo!
Get those gains.
Yeah, run that treadmill.
You know what?
I think you need to do a big- okay, actually, no, don't do a bigger.
Don't do a weight.
Don't lift things that are- that are too- too big, guys.
Care about your safety.
Anyway, woo!
Lift those weights.
That's right.
You can do- guys, is this motivating enough?
Damn, bro, you're getting so big.
Whoa, do you work out?
Whoa, bro.
Whoa, is that two- is that two pound, um, two pound barbell?
Damn.
Slow down, dude.
You're gonna break your hand with that two pounder.
Whoa, I'm motivated.
Bro, two- two pound.
Oh, don't you- a whole- a whole two pounds?
Oh my god, maybe you should do one pound.
Oh my god, I'm worried.
I'm scared for you.
I-
Sorry, sorry, uh, that might not be motivating anymore.
I'm sorry.
I got a little- that might be, uh, that might be demotivating.
Um, let's see.
Uh, Laffy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh my god, you- oh, you guys almost distracted me enough.
Into the trash you go.
There's your- there's your five minute billboard space.
I looked at the clock.
That's a key, right?
Right, that's your two dollar- that's your- that's your five minute ad space.
We got- we're done here.
Um, can you give us a proper pronunciation?
You're famous.
Um, as a sound clip.
All right, that's- that's it.
That's basically it.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Um, yeah, anyway, thank you for the super chat.
If you have a cringy promotional quote like, What a nice morning for mischief, or I'm just here for the boobs.
What would it be?
Wait, is that the promotional quote?
There's no way.
I've never heard her ever say that.
I never heard her say that before.
I don't fuck y'all.
Buy my merch.
That's- that's the most promotional thing.
I can say, buy my merch.
I literally say that after every convention.
They'll be like, do you have any special messages you have to give them, Toki?
And I literally just be like, buy my merch, and then that's it.
She use it.
I- I like- I literally say that after every convention.
I- that's my special message.
I'll just be like, buy it.
It's direct, right?
It's- direct, and like, you know, people buy my merch after that.
I literally said that.
I remember I said that for ACGHK in Hong Kong.
I was like, buy my merch.
I have a stand right there.
And then literally, there was a line right after.
And everything sold out.
And I was like, see?
It's that easy.
True.
It's- it's literally that easy.
Yeah, it just works.
That's promotional.
It's promotional.
Because people be like, well, she has merch right here that I can spend money on.
I'm like, yeah, there it is.
It's over there.
Don't need anything fancy.
It's just very direct.
And people laugh and be like, ha ha, silly doki.
That's so funny.
And I'm just here.
I was like, no, seriously, buy my merch.
I get a laugh every time.
And I'm just thinking it's working.
I'm just like, well, you might think it's funny, but it's working.
And then they do it.
Yeah.
Yeah, it's a subliminal- it's not even subliminal messaging.
It's like, It's like direct messaging.
Um...
Let's see.
Uh, Cypher, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Uh, I have a specific voice request.
No specific line, because I want a true authentic joke.
Some motivation for me to go draw, please.
Hey, draw.
Now.
And then just draw me though.
If you're trying to draw other people, who cares?
If you're drawing me, finish that shit right now.
Is that...
You should draw me now.
Is that motivating enough?
But if it's like something unrelated to me, who the fuck cares?
If it's me, finish that shit right now.
Um...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah, draw only Doki.
And also like Doki dad, too.
Dad's fine as well.
Doki Amber Doge is fine.
And in my many forms.
Uh...
Not a space alien.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Uh, am I late for the mandatory sub?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Duck, thank you for the magenta super.
Um, I love some Doki inspirational audio.
Uh, I want... okay.
Okay.
All right.
I want you to know, dragons.
No matter what happens, you can do it.
But if you can't, that's okay, too.
Like...
That's all right.
It's like... it's all right to be a little lazy.
Just like me right now.
I should be doing work after this, because I told my management team.
I was like, oh, don't worry.
It's gonna be a fast stream, where I just...
Uh, where I just like, you know, remember to announce this and stream a little bit longer.
And then we're good to go, because I have a lot of work to do after this.
But I'm like...
Thank you for the magenta super.
Thank you.
Um...
Mason, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right.
I'm not like other streamers.
I'm worse.
Wait, that's it?
Wait.
Wait a minute.
No, you can fix me.
Isn't that... guys, I am the... you can fix me experience.
You hear about all the things... no, we can't.
All right.
What do you mean?
I can improve.
I can... that's crazy.
No, don't give up, guys.
Guys.
No.
There's baby steps.
Baby steps, everybody.
Baby, I am the parenting slash you can fix her experience.
Um, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Um, while your nendoroid won't be the first piece of merch I got, it'll be the one I'll own with pride and honor.
That's good.
I mean, I hope so.
I'm so excited though.
Guys, pre-order is out.
It's out now.
Remember to pre-order with that link.
Click on the link, guys.
Click on the link, everybody.
Because someday it's... I think it's a tracking link.
So you can track how many people click the link.
So, like, click on that link, guys.
Don't just google it.
Just click on that link because it's directly there.
I hope that's good.
I'm glad you all pre-ordered it.
I think it looks really good, too.
I think, like, the nendoroid itself looks really, really good in general.
Because, like, I don't know.
Like, the paint job, it's so pretty.
The paint job in general is really pretty.
Um...
Uh, Steve, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
We live in a society, Steven.
Uh...
I clicked it.
Was it the same link?
Did it have the nccw2l on it?
Did it have that?
Was... is there still too many?
Wait, just wait, guys.
Just wait.
It'll be your turn soon.
Medi, thank you for the magenta super.
Thank you.
Congrats on 800k, Doki.
We have a small project we're working on that could use your voice.
Could you say...
Croak you want a cracker?
Uh...
Does that work?
Oh, there's a... oh my god, you guys made something on my intro?
Wait, what is it?
Sorry, I was so busy.
There's so many stuff I had to do today.
So many, like, announcements in general, too.
I was just like...
So busy.
Busy, busy girl.
I'm such a busy, busy person.
Oh, yeah, I haven't watched it.
I was gonna do a reaction to some of the Game Awards stuff, but...
um...
I don't know.
The Pac-Man shit was so funny, because, like, remember what I talked about?
I was like, what the fuck is that trailer?
And apparently, the trailer basically spoiled the game and stuff.
So, like, the new Pac-Man game is, like, some fucking crazy gothic shit.
Like, I don't even... it looked fucking crazy.
I was just like...
I was watching it.
I was like, the fuck am I... what the fuck is this?
It's so weird.
You know, that was so fucking weird.
I was like, oh my god.
All right, let's see, what is it?
What is the... oh, it's my intro!
Intro!
Oh, that's so cool!
Yes, they made my intro with cosplayers!
That's so cute!
Bum, bum, bum.
I would post... I would show it, like, on my screen, but, like, um...
I'm worried about, like, because I don't have it where, like, it streams, whatever.
Like, I have it so that whatever I put on my OBS shows instantly.
So, I was, like, a little worried if I try to...
because I need to, like, pre-set it up if I'm doing anything on the internet.
So...
So, I'm, like, worried I'd fuck it up when I share...
Oh my god!
That's so cute!
That's so cute with all the cosplayers, too!
With all the different cosplayers!
Oh my god!
I love it.
You can switch OBS to studio mode at will?
I should try to learn that.
How do I do studio mode?
What is that?
What do you mean by that?
Where's studio?
I should... because I know, like, Mint has it so that, uh...
Mint has it so that she, like, um, instantly, she, like, Mint has it so that she can put something on her screen and it doesn't instantly show, uh, where, where it is and stuff like that.
Oh, it is!
I should learn that.
But I shouldn't learn that right now because what if I fuck it up, guys?
But yes, I am, even though I've been streaming for, like, so long now, I'm still, like, I still don't know what the fuck I'm doing.
I...
Because, you know, when you, like, get into a habit of, like, things you already know how to do, so then you're like, I don't need to learn anything new now.
I already know everything I have to know, um, and stuff like that.
So that's why I'm, like, I'm just, like, coasting when it comes to, like, OBS stuff.
Um, okay.
I'm gonna close voice requests right now because, um, I think there's a lot I have to do.
So, I'm gonna close it now and finish it up, and then we're gonna call it here.
All right, burrito!
Thank you.
All right.
I'm gonna say this once and that's all you get.
You're just my adorable little pod champ.
All right.
Anyway, netbirds, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Do you have a single fact that to back that up?
I look like I stumbled upon that.
That's ten dollars.
Uh, mystic Tony, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Um, and I gotta tell you, it was perfect.
Perfect!
Everything down to the last minute details.
I'm Homelander.
I'm the VTuber Homelander.
Oh, wait, I shouldn't be.
He's fucked up.
I don't like the new- I didn't- I didn't like the new season of the boys.
To be fair, the comic book series- the comic book- I read the comic book and it's pretty, um, the- the TV adaptation improved the comic book a lot because the comic book is like edgy.
It's like so fucking edgy to a point where some of the edginess did not make sense.
I was like, they did not- they just- they did shock factor stuff for the sake of shock factor.
No, the last- yeah, the last season it was pretty mid.
Honestly, it was really fucking mid for me.
Um, Yeah, so honestly, like, yeah, the- the person who made the comic book series really fucking hated superheroes.
So he just like wrote the worst possible like adaptation of like superheroes possible just to show- just to be like how much he hates superheroes.
Um, but like to be fair, they had not a lot to build on with the whole superhero stuff.
So like I don't blame them.
Not- not superhero.
They had not a whole lot to put- deal with for the uh, for the uh, the boys series.
Also speaking of superheroes, I- I criticized the Marvel movies in my first- in my Marvel Rivals stream because I was like, oh, yeah I don't really pay much attention to Marvel movies after a certain point because like I said it was so formulaic at that point and like I felt like a lot of them are like not as good anymore and then someone in my- someone commented and was like,
how fucking dare you.
They are- they are like works of art and then I'm- and then like today apparently that newest Marvel movie, the- what was it called?
The- Matt like- The one that apparently people are saying is absolute fucking shit and um
No, he- they wrote like Like it was a very long paragraph.
It was several paragraphs long.
Oh, yeah Craven the Hunter They- they released like Craven the Hunter and I just want- and I'm just like thinking works of art.
All right
Um Yeah Like yeah, they're like They were a very passionate Marvel fan and I'm like, yeah to each their own, you know That's what opinions are for but just thought it was really funny because I- I feel like, you know I think my opinion is not that controversial Like I feel like they are pretty formulaic now and they're very predictable.
Um Because they named Deadpool versus Wolverine As an example of like how great Marvel movies movies are and I'm like It was all right Ha It was basically what you expect from a Deadpool movie Like it was formulaic As a Deadpool movie, but it was a fun movie.
I wouldn't call it mass like a work of art But it was a fun movie like
Oh my god, what was that?
Oh my god I hear- what was that?
Oh my god, oh, it's the twitter the twitter thing replaying itself.
Oh my god, that scared the shit out of me Sorry, my my my my the the 800k video replayed itself and it scared me because I was like, where did that come from?
But yeah, I just thought it was really funny, you know, you can name a lot of other Marvel movies but like I I You I would not say Deadpool versus Wolverine was a fucking work of art when I watched Deadpool versus Wolverine and like 50% of like like No,
it 90% of that.
It's just like hey remember that guy he's here, too I like That's just like I wouldn't call that a work of art Is it like oh there's also that guy we got we got him in too.
Oh my god, there's that guy as well.
Whoa Oh, man, we could have got this person but we couldn't afford him
So So i'm just i'm just like I liked it.
It was a fun movie.
I wouldn't fucking call it a work of art.
That's the thing I wouldn't it's just a mindless movie that have to turn your brain off and have fun That's it, which we need more of that to be fair We need fun movies, but like yeah
Oh my god Anyway uh Let's see All right, thank you Thank you.
Thank you Now garfield's a work of art.
I can't believe you would fucking say that to me Garfield is a work of art the guy jim davis He literally made garfield because he was like, I just want to make a lot of fucking money and that is There was no bullshit reason as to why he made garfield there was no Bullshit he literally was just like I want to make a lot of fucking money and then I did it
And then he did it it was just not he was not inspired by anything he didn't do it for like Artistical reasons or like creative reasons.
He was like what can make me so much fucking money No No, no pretentiousness or anything.
No vision, you know, like um, calvin and hobbes the the creator Who's like really against capital like, you know merchandising capitalism?
like and he's just like he wanted to be like more philosophical about the world and like um Talk about different viewpoints and everything and garfield is like fuck.
I just want money
And then he was like, I just want to make a lot of fucking money and then he did it mystic tony Then you know super chat thing you think yeah, I like calvin hobbes, too But you have to admit at the late you like calvin hobbes But do you like have you read all of the calvin and hobbes comic book strips?
Because like you can tell when someone says I like calvin hobbes, but they only like they've only like read the p the
calvin and hobbes, uh Calvin hobbes.
I like how it helps too.
But like you can tell at one point he got super philosophical um, and like the direction and then it like direction of that changed a lot Because you remember a lot of the you remember some of the comic strips that were like, um That were like, uh, you know more more easier to understand and everything But there are some comic book strips That from calvin hobbes where he got like where child would not understand what the fuck he was talking about
I don't remember which one it was it was I remember I don't remember which which Which comic strip it was but there was one where they were discussing about like like political systems I was like what the fuck Cuz I was really young when I was reading it and I was I was really young when I was reading it cuz I was like I was just like obviously I didn't know what the what fuck was but I was just like Okay
But when you get older you appreciate it more because it was a very smart comic book like it was a very smart comic series There was a very yeah, it literally they're named after philosophy, but yeah, but child me did not know that Guys, like now I know they're named after philosophers cuz I'm a fucking adult now But child me when I did not know Know anything about philosophy back there.
Oh My god Um, but it's a really good comic series I you know admire that like he didn't he didn't sell out and I also might admire Jim Davis for selling out And as Snoopy is like the middle ground I feel like I really Snoopy is like the middle ground between selling out and not selling out because they they like hand-picked on like how to sell like Snoopy the creator of Snoopy is like You know,
they're they're very careful not to create I don't even know if he's still alive, but like the pew ever owns the brand of Snoopy They pick and choose exactly how to sell out because they're like, they don't you know Garfield's like if I can put my name on it,
I'm gonna put my name on it.
Snoopy was like, okay, wait here I'm gonna fucking you know Pick and choose Exactly how I'm gonna sell out.
So I'm not gonna put my name on Everything I'm just gonna put my name on some things
You gotta feel it is like if if I can merchandise this fucking put my name on it Why are eyes bugged out what do you mean my eyes are up here Nendoroids are out now pre-ordered by my merch or Pre-order my merch cuz it's not out yet.
Oh Gen X saying in the super chat.
Thank you.
Congrats on the 800k.
Oh, thank you very very super chat.
Thank you Thank you.
It's not subtle.
It's a direct order pre-order it now So we can get the cow the cowboy yee-haw bounty hunting android maybe I have a melody box that plays the sound of greeting when I turn on my car Can you give me a greeting or something funny to put on it?
Here is something funny to put it in your silly little car.
Oh, it's a big car Maybe it's not that silly to your something.
I don't know but now you have a very long greeting.
Thank you for the super chat
Brian the newest super chat thing you think
My source is that I made it the fuck up.
Oh That's oh, that's the oh, okay.
Yeah.
No, that's everything I say.
No, not everything guys Sometimes I say right things.
So nice.
I spread misinformation and sometimes my information is correct It's your job to figure out what is right or you can just believe everything
Alan the newest super chat thing and thank you.
Oh, no boobs.
Oh while crying Okay, all right Alan
Nice try I did say this is like budget cameo
Um What the fuck dracoons what the fuck is a dracoon Okay Jarhuds, they give you the super chat thinking.
Thank you.
What about a motivational thread about us being dracoons?
For increasing our energy and madness.
It'll be cool Honk legion rise up who is a good dragoon?
What is your profession?
Wait, is that what?
Is that what you want me to say?
Right fucking quit being a clown
We're on the circus now, I'm disowning all clown dragons
She's dead now
She left the circus she graduated from the clown college it's gone
You're reintegrating into society in the dragoon society, don't be freaks guys you're reintegrating it back into our society You don't wonder what happened to the cheek dots You know what become like that cheek dots dragons you're you're Circus
Yeah, your own little you're reintegrating back in
I You're like cooler cheek dots exactly who were they who were they
All right You know, it's crazy.
I saw some people cuz it pops up in my recommended I don't interact with them like mint does because like, you know, she loves stocking
I Do too, but like I do it privately She like lets you know that you're like, she's like always watching but I do it privately So like you don't know if I'm watching or not So like everything you tweet you're like, I wonder if Doki's reading this I might be anyway so like,
you know during my like I'm saying as if my clown arc lasted like was like three weeks ago or some shit, even though it literally lasted the last three days, but I Was like like I'm like going through memory lane.
Oh, man.
Remember that clown arc I had, you know It's literally yesterday and a day before but anyway, um, I saw some people who were like Seeing me as a clown and they're like this awakened something inside me and then like people were like Welcome to the who is it called?
like oh My god, can't even say that
Oh Okay, it's fine.
So like, you know, like bussy so like people are like, oh my god Can I see and I'm like what the fuck?
This is why this is why we're separating you from the regular dragoons
Thing oh, it's to be fair.
I'm King shaming I'm like, there's a lot of things out there.
I'm just I'm shaming
You get your own little corner Yeah, I reintegrate or you're in your little corner don't mind the bones there don't mind the bones of these old dragons They never existed
Game being a little super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you With marble rivals here.
Can I get a another epic victory dragon?
And ah, you'll get him next time to help me get through rank.
I'm struggling out here.
Oh shit.
What rank are you?
But then if I laugh, I'm sorry
All right rock thing, you know super chat thing you think you Look forward to that.
You guys can't laugh at him because I don't think you're any better Except for penny that guy named penny Parker apparently their top 500 now and they're a big fan of me But they still sold my elo wait guys Okay, if you're a penny Parker who took my elo and was saying how you're a big fan You tell me who you can't tell me if you're in my chat right now I really want to know who you are so I can give you I'll mod you I'll moderate you if you show me who you are right now.
I
Don't Just saying I'm gonna say don't you want mod anyone that beats me in a video game and there's a drag moon In rank, by the way, not like some fucking random custom In rank in top 500 you should show yourself to my chat up chat and you'll get modded
Oh Guys oh my god, I was gonna say something so edgy
Fuck no, I can't this is a sponsored segment.
I shouldn't say it
I Can't I'm trying to sell my nendoroid.
I'm trying to Try to sell my nendoroid.
I can't say it It was just very like current times Something we're like, I'm not and it's related as something that's current And you can sort of guess what I was gonna say
Let's see, let's see
Oh We're doing my suppose.
Oh, they're your rocky rock steel Titan Damn it there.
You forgot to pay the water bill again.
Now.
I have to cook the lobster and tequila lime.
I hate lobster Yeah, I don't know I never liked lobster I know lobster is like super expensive but I never liked lobster in general I Don't know.
I just don't like taste of it.
I just feel like the taste of is weird I like imitation crab, which is in lobsters I know like, you know I always think I don't know why I thought imitation crab was crab when it literally says imitation crab because it's literally just a bunch Of fish stuff squashed together like sausages.
It's basically the fish sausage of the world.
It's not even crab.
I Don't like I don't know lobster, you know, I just don't like the taste of it.
Um But where was I I don't even know.
Where was I in the super chats?
I'm so sorry guys.
Oh Sick they give me a first super chat.
Thank you.
I have a voice box thing that oh, I already said Oh, I already read that.
I read that one Champion man, then you wait.
Did I I did a full screening for another car?
Oh, this is a different guy Oh my god, you both have voice box things for your cars All right, sick.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Um, oh My gosh, I should what do I say?
It's oh my god, what do I say I'm on the spot what I say when you fucking start your car broom broom don't hit
Don't hit anyone
All right, fine, okay broom broom don't hit anyone
Don't do it Every time you start your car you get you get like good advice, you know
Oh Champion thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you Chris abroad.
Yeah Super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you
Okay, um Let's see, wait, what's that?
No, oh my god.
Oh I closed it just when you guys sent it.
All right guys Voice request closed.
Oh my god stream for two hours.
That's crazy.
I did not feel like two hours All right, guys, that was fun though.
I love fun chat.
I hope you guys had fun to hang out with me today.
Um What a lot Long day today, but thank you guys for coming.
I really appreciate it chat Yeah, then the right is out now So make sure make sure you get your pre-orders in because it does help a lot With grinding like the sales of it and like future collaborations with good smile.
So yeah, you guys wanted more stuff okay, now I'll show my eyes now, so
I'll show my eyes now, but like, you know, if you guys You guys want more future stuff with good smile I really encourage you guys to pre-order it and support the pre-order and get your own very own Jokey bird then dry.
Thank you everybody as always everyone stay hydrated posture check Give him around to get that blood flowing and if you step for me head to bed cuz you deserve it I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye I'll play the trailer again, too Bye
Pose A little dragon she holds in her hand Be aware.
The true form is a tomato so be on the lookout Suspect me found standing on a special nendoroid base with her signature on it Oh, she got away again!
Catch me if you can, dragons.
Wait, secret ending.
Did they announce Silksong yet?
They didn't, right?